county school district is now back in
session as you know that started
yesterday after that five day pause
while this did allow a little time for
staff to catch up there are still
employees and students who are out the
alcoholman live in studio with a look at
some of those numbers
good morning john and heather at least
23 schools have double-digit coveted
cases this is the most recent update
reported over the five-day stop the
spread pulse for clark county schools so
one case in particular that stands out
is arbor view high school at least 21
high schools had double double-digit
increases in coven 19 cases 37 new cases
were reported at
arbor view dr monica cortez assistant
superintendent of student services
division says there's no intent to
switch to distance learning but they
already are ready to make the switch if
absolutely necessary
i really believe that if we continue
moving forward cautiously looking at our
indicators that we've been looking at
and keeping the communication lines open
with our families and our staff will be
moving in the right direction to
continue in person learning
so there are three other high schools a
spring valley clark and paolo verde they
all saw cases increased by 27 over the
past five five-day period so coming up
in the next half hour we're going to
share more about a middle school that
was impacted by new coven 19 cases
biancholman live local now